here we are again ouch on the couch I
brought food with me it wouldn't be a
worth episode without food we are doing
the show where we watch old episodes of
worth it
mm-hmm doesn't have an official name yet
we get some ideas right from the the
tube comments yeah I don't hear them one
worth it
aftertaste I know aftertaste
I feel like always has a negative aspect
to it you're rarely like wow what if it
wasn't aftertaste extra bytes a little
more appetizing okay sound bites okay
yeah got you there the was it worth it
was it worth it
not bad it doesn't totally hold up to
logic because it was always worth it
Adam what are we doing today yeah
you can't hold this to me for the rest
of my life it was at that moment of time
when Adam texted me I was sitting down
on my couch watching something else and
oh fish yeah
so please I want to say I got the same
text and it took me a long time to
respond for two guys okay to be fair to
us fish we turn this around we can we
talk about that yeah wait hold on load
up first of all great title shout at you
Josh our editor who I'm pretty sure was
the guy who put that together yeah but
that's great a perfects work right there
very profesh but we do this thing where
so Adams always oh well this is white
cream cheese on a white sweater just
brush it on okay sorry
so anyway long story short Adam is
filming us you know facing this way and
then we always get a secondary angle to
cut to to help with editing so in this
take Adam just at the end of shooting
that section Adam just walks around to
the back of us with the camera and then
it's that shot which is really funny
because we do these like silly
fabrications to make it feel like a show
that's bigger than it is but it's really
just the three of em hey don't give a
few kids away though it's a fun secret
so this is in Hawaii and of course
Hawaii wasn't that supposed to do it
yeah because we were going to wipe all
right so this entire trip was like
motivated by getting this one location
for a different episode and then because
we were traveling there we thought we're
gonna Hawaii let's make some more
episodes and so we did fish yeah we one
of my favorite locations ever yes yeah
this is this oh and daddy also coming up
later oh oh yeah okay they're all great
yeah this one is so cool it's basically
like just people who really like to fish
and then they were like holy crap you
have all these fish okay yeah watch the
episode if you want to learn more go out
here right now
thanks that oh sorry gets swept up in
the magic of our content classic out of
the trunk of the car drive No
we've done that a lot usually when they
have a way to go menu right well they
have no dining inside yeah
after this video aired five minutes now
sure I don't want to toot my own horn or
our own or the worth it for too much
right now but there was an article
written they interviewed Erica and Josh
afterward
yeah and they said that their business
actually quadruple now right after the
new came out it's pretty wild
there's the collar a collar so cool
I find that the best issue that
restaurants are oftentimes money we have
this extra thing that we don't know what
to do with you can throw it away yeah
we're making good dish right and this
look at look at that
yes happening she's like it was very
sharp so I think I jabbed you a little
bit that's all right this oh my gosh I'm
booking my plate right now
everybody in this episode is so friendly
and like the restaurants are all very
family-oriented even in the last place
which we haven't gotten to yet but the
Aloha spirit yeah it was real I was
always this is actually my first time in
Hawaii ever for this episode and it's
that thing you always hear about you're
like a little skeptical like is it a
thing but it's true like truly you feel
it everywhere you go I love shot I love
whenever we get a chef that's just like
look at my fish so a little bow oh it
was so muttering softly to eat I have
never seen a fish look this way
mochi crusted Onaga yeah looks like a
like a chicken cutlet I just realized my
second is the birds coming in probably
eat the fish just like me yeah
their infamous alignment so that I think
Adams saying drizzle me is actually in
reference to a previous video where you
said sizzle me with your zest there's
like something you had to squeeze a
lemon on - I'm gonna let them I'm gonna
let the viewers look this up for
themselves you she's gonna have to do
some investigative work on your own to
find this video oh I forgot about this
desert this looks incredible brulee oh
that's you yeah yeah hey so over to on
site here behind the scenes when we're
filming the dishes being made Adam is
usually operating the camera with the
wider lens is it Adam yeah and then I'm
operating one with a very tight macro
which is kind of like a double-edged
sword like sometimes you get the best
shot but usually you record just blurry
nonsense this is one of those times
where he'll done you didn't go to school
for these Idols well yeah that dessert
was incredible I mean Hawaii the fruit
available is tropical flavors that's one
of the yeah one of the best places to
have dessert for sure one of the best
series of desserts we've had on the show
Hawaii food is low-key so incredible
maybe Taiki but there's just so many
cultural influences that come from
referre Western and Eastern influences
yeah and you're gonna want to eat good
food when you're on an island like that
like it's just so that actually the
thing the thing you just said took a lot
of research but there's a distinction
between Hawaii food and Hawaiian food
where I believe Hawaiian food is food
that is indigenous to the island and
then Hawaii food is what you're talking
about
it's like mixture of cuisines like the
Japanese the
dizziness everything mixed together
that's what makes us great - yeah
location of this episode is the Hawaii
food that's right the first location is
Hawaiian food yeah the second one is
food in Hawaii my friends that are not
Hawaiian
like non-indigenous yeah okay oh you're
Hawaiian like no no no I'm from Hawaii
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah so every smile
of the deficits of money because the
cocktail location Oh worthy of the price
for sure also this is what this just
like this guy alone one of the coolest
guys we've ever interviewed on the show
in my opinion he's just like dripping
with cool elegance I don't know you know
it's like the glasses his look at family
I honestly and I follow him on Instagram
it's pretty fun right yeah he like still
runs marathons it's crazy so we were
just talking about that difference of
Hawaiian cuisine in Hawaii regional
cuisine mm-hm so chef Mauro back in the
day was one of the first chefs to
formalize this idea of Hawaii regional
cuisine with what he was doing he was
taking his classic French training and
understanding of ingredients and then
applying it to the local ingredients
that is what makes Hawaii so special the
vast resources that they have to write
and the TASIS rewatching this episode I
I'm like getting that feeling that I had
when I was there and I was like man I
lived in Honolulu I'd be like chef Mauro
like running marathons up into my 70s
like surfing after work I had decided
I'm going to go to home two months
should we just do a new episode there
let's do it
fish to the sequel see Cuomo
heuu etc
I remember it after a mess I it was
maybe one of the times when I had no
words describe yeah how good yeah it was
yeah I remember a very similar feeling I
was just thinking wow this is a really
good for you this is gonna sound
ridiculous because I know that we just
interviewed a Frenchman to move July but
when I eat this [ __ ] the first thing I
think of is a Frenchman who moved to
Hawaii and made the most delicious fishy
good I felt like a child love French me
to move to Hawaii and made the most
delicious fish because yeah I think Adam
actually had the best line yet in the
pace death here oh that looks like the
delicious biscuit that's covered in
sugar right now I want to eat it but it
does look like a tasty doesn't it do
that like a scone weight makes sense the
movie with Robert De Niro Adam you gotta
be out you gotta have a talk and we're
all the show more often you get you say
some pretty good stuff house yeah I say
some stupid stuff MW restaurant they
just do such a good job they're like
everything is delicious but my words a
Twinner chef Maru whoa whoa surprise
myself
your chef Andrew there's wannabe chef
maverick what was your worth it with I
do want to be chef RORO
they killed it
[Laughter]
very good three is that a third angle
who edited this Josh Richardson well
done Josh safe right Frank
oh great great phrase is it not Frank
you said Frank the cost of scaring the
fish today and who's your weather winner
the creme brulee okay pause real quick
hold up I do that once on the show where
I'm like oh yeah I choose the Puckle in
the chicken episode everybody goes nuts
in the comments and Adam listen every
single episode and nobody cares yeah
that's sad is it warm
oh it's nice next episode where we do
next
bye fine hi guys bye I wanna be a
fisherman you're a fish couple times as
a kid a lot more crabbing oh no that was
our crab fish no they're not you catch a
fish if anything we've learned
oh don't watch at the end of the video
oh wow
my favorite thing to do is to say things
like I know what I'm talking about but I
truly don't I did do a lot of crabbing
him hit that Jersey Shore yeah when we
started watching this I thought Oh
Steven picked wrong the fish episode
really that's the one but now rewatching
a that is a very good episode I just
look back at it very very long that's
the word Fonda Lee Han Lee yes yeah it's
definitely one of those episodes that
feels like it's really part of the place
where we shot it you know sometimes
we'll go to a restaurant in a city like
just for the particular restaurant yeah
but this episode really feels like a
travel pro right more than some of the
previous ones it could be a Hawaii
episode right yeah cool I like that a
lot
yeah I want to make more episodes like
that are we gonna do your favorite
episode in a future episode so that's it
for now this has been worth it watches
worth it official title TBD yeah see you
again
bye
[Music]